okay well for people who are on the
livestream welcome to a evening edition
of our inside software architecture
series this is a late stage design
discussion and documentation session for
a software engineering piece of
functionality that's going into the next
version of off language and so let's get
going so there's a function called
system install which is supposed to
download software on a machine and let's
see so I can try actually running this
the next cone was that right it should
be system install Python why doesn't it
autocomplete it should autocomplete that
term agree what's gonna do okay um first
thing is you see this you know legal you
know agreement thing like hey you're
about to do something that's not covered
by over language license okay that could
be more beautifully formatted obviously
sure yeah
I mean why don't we what's the title
here I mean it should be something like
Wolfram language system let's see
what should we call it welcome language
system install for Python or something
off Python or from language system
install of Python
but sounds reasonable okay did this did
this some who I mean this is just looks
kind of ugly
so I mean literally this is very basic
dialogue if you think it needs to be
designed I think it I don't know it
doesn't I don't think it's that
important I think that they're working
they forget the the verbiage from you
then we can get you know design to this
I can a designer get legal to come up
with what the verbage should be this is
really not difficult okay
I mean presumably there's licensing in
you to point to where that licensing is
I don't know what it is okay so now what
happens here
oh I see it's got a whole installer it's
also got a whole bunch but okay so I see
I understand so so that initial screen
is just saying you're gonna be taken to
an external installer why don't we just
show you that you understand it's but
but okay so here and then there are a
bunch of bugs here yeah so the bugs are
actually the process like this is
definitely not making it as a non
experimental thing downloads and
installs okay
I don't think it necessarily simplifies
it
uh well so the interactive off if you
said interactive goes to false for a
Python for example it can run you know
in the background why don't we just say
manages the installation and
configuration of external systems used
by certain um well called by certain
language functions
systems cysts include
okay
you
lovely okay this looks just fine to me
all good gonna make one yeah has the
spin netted no no it's okay and also
dozen guys rectum yeah it does it is
from there
okay I want to check the back like check
the back legs
you
yep
we do have to talk about what guide
pages maybe should be on yeah that's
what we need to do next
um let's also put that in there although
we're not finished with this page yet
okay let's look at guide pages um so
should we take it from
open the main page
um let's see this is clearly going in
external
gosh this all kinds of junk here um
let's see
set up or what where is um oh this is
probably okay hold on
by the way network programming
choose
okay
well this is relevant for
right for now it's relevant here
hopefully system install will get lots
of other functionality as well
yeah that's a plaintiff more MORE
it'll stop wearing there but no J let's
put this in here so is no Jess coming
for this version or not I just have no
Jess I mean sorry sister install install
external software systems
maybe see about character and Nicolas
doing it Ian if you you know um give
somebody else or something to do
you
you
we could say software for an external
attack
install software for external evaluators
but reasonable
gods more general it can also be done
the network packet capture and well
money is on the page Forex external
interpreted language interfaces
in that context you make sense right
okay what's next
even the network packet capture
documentation right yep yep that's
that's look what just tell one this is
just failed now let me just try this
again um I know that worked that was I
think you were switched into Xcaret the
exocrine all built high because when you
connected okay so it's never packet
capture in the main head branch build or
is it only external it's supposed to be
in the main bridge I haven't checked
recent it wasn't as if this weekend it
might be in 11.8 check it so that's
there so network packet capture and the
interface you see it's still okay well
no it's not okay so let's try it in the
external yeah the interface is old do we
have a mock-up of the new one yep if you
give me one sec I can send you this and
then
okay so there are my packets so this is
this is final as far as you're concerned
for how these but what's happening with
the look of all these packets the the
dataset is well or ordering the ordering
of the columns I think you asked a
change and I haven't gotten around to
changing the order okay that symbol de
to change the order okay so this is a
mock-up of so that the top one this is
almost drowned in fermenting that's cool
average packets per second wait a minute
but that's not indicating an average
packets per second is it right so so we
decided it's a significant amount of
development to get it to work when you
just pull it up to have and so and so
the decision that we made was that when
you pull it up there's like nothing
dynamic and that it doesn't start
updating or anything until you actually
click record
so then when you click record then it
starts recording and will tell you the
number of packets per second the time
why does it display average packets per
second where it has nothing to say I
mean that should be masked out when it
has nothing to say
okay here we can hide out here let's
hide a bowl right yeah yeah we can just
make that an empty string or an empty
yeah where is it saying on what the
interfaces being zero whatever you
mentioned you didn't want that there why
not because it's by default it will
capture on all interfaces I see I see
and you have to tell it to capture on a
particular interface yep and that
specified routes with the arguments to
the function when you call it
okay do you think this is obvious enough
I mean this is a recording button just
like a audio recording button right I
think yeah why is that it bothers me
that this thing is gray and it bothers
me on the audio case as well because it
seems like it seems like it's grayed out
somehow is it is it in fact today on the
audio case okay let me try and recording
here blah blah blah that's really weird
that it's gray like that okay um
new
it's supposed to be
[Music]
gosh that's not good that oh no Dexter
Dexter no it's what's supposed to happen
is spectrogram object is supposed to
display as the spectrogram graphic
am i making sense
um could uh Carla could you check into
that please sure that would normally be
Shari's thing but charlie is I believe
out of contact right now okay but you
can check in 11 3 it may just this may
just be an experiment and all the
external you know that there's going
well no I know that they're trying to
get this in 411 3 because this is
maintaining our information about the
spectrogram to know what the sampling
frequency is and things like that so you
can do other computations on it ok so so
in you've got an implementation of this
nice dynamic thing is that true almost
well I don't have a completed
implementation I could show you right
now ok ok good Carla could you also flag
with design the fact that I really think
this great thing is confusing yeah I
think they should use a color other than
gray which looks great out okay any
preference of the color for though I
haven't a clue I'll give it to them
um darker right not like grey indicates
just imagine I'm looking great out
that's all um unless they make an
argument that it's the right thing but
then I think it's it's ok all right
let's take a look at network packet
capture Network packet capture wait a
minute didn't we just have a network
packet capture open/close didn't that
just do this
oh right yes I forgot to add that usage
line yes that's that's the first usage
line
oh come on why did that do that
okay so this is Network packet capture
no arguments and record the zoom throws
but for anybody out there know how
that's working okay so
what do we want to say here we want to
say something that's analogous to what
we say for audio capture and what are we
calling the sewed Network packet
recording as analogous to if I say
network packet recording is that right
at what packet recording of yep that
should be fine one thing I'll show you
my shotty about is that they think that
we should rename it to be similar to
audio where it's a network packet record
use no no no no no I talked to shadi and
they're renaming audio - audio recording
oh okay well then must I have an after I
talked to shadi right so Carla can you
track that down and make sure that
really happens okay
sorry what was the last thing you get
action 81 Stephen coming from you said
um that that audio recording be changed
from audio record to audio recording
you
yeah I don't think there's any reason to
default to anything therefore okay
creates a temporary interactive
interface for capturing an audio signal
that would seem to me to be what we want
to say here as well
creates a temporary interactive
interface for capturing
our records
it's on all
network devices right
that is called order by default
capturing information on network packets
you
on all
to face network interfaces is that right
I'm not sure you need to repeat network
network packets because it's in the name
already just capturing collecting but Oh
capturing information on all network on
network packets
it's just a little wordy but if they
like it that's free no I liked repeating
the name in the function because I think
it says why the function is called that
okay
Network packets
let's say transmitted or received by all
network interfaces
on your computer but right by all access
I confess all network interfaces
I mean I mean technically it's
accessible I mean if if you're trying if
you know it will attempt to capture
packets on every interface it's just
that if you don't have you know if that
interface is inactive or something
it'll just silently not no packets will
show up on it so I don't know how I mean
I think all is fine okay um through
work interfaces through all network
interfaces
a little better
[Music]
buddy care okay
what are these things here
so what's this tea call my serve I don't
think you want tea call my serve right
yeah that was probably a holdover from
from when I copied and pasted this from
okay so
are you calling it network service or
network interface no this is something
different network services is distinct
that's like HTTP right oh so okay so
where does that appear in the
association here so it doesn't because
we can't retrospectively you know figure
out what I mean we can tell you what
poured it on and we could try and figure
out hey what service but not every
packet that sent over a specific port is
of a particular protocol or service okay
so what do you what what do you mean
hand by the summons so that if let's see
if I have any no I don't have an example
but so that would be if you do like
control equals of HTTP you could do
network packet capture of control equals
of HTTP which is a network service
entity that we have documented okay hold
on so this is a pretty sophisticated
thing actually so I mean if I say okay
network packet capture of control equals
HTTP
supercool right fine so now I'll get
great yeah sorry this is from the merge
fallout okay but what is it do with you
so what this does is it's as if you said
so that entity has like a ports property
in it and and so we look up the port
numbers for that network service and we
capture on those ports okay if I if I
set HTTP have quotes HTTP would it also
have looked if it's a name yes I think
that most what what what the heck else
is a what is it cold as it port no
what's it called like network you might
have to do property Association
default ports yeah something like that
that's okay but so what exactly can
occur there so so that is an entity so
the service can be specified as an
entity or a string presumably yes and
for the string case we just rely on
entity to try and turn it into a network
interface and if it fails then you know
what happens if I just want a particular
port number
so then you would use the key goes to
fowl and you would say pork goes to AE
or or just why don't we just support n
for a port when we just support a port
number just you know eighty means port
80 okay I mean yeah we I don't think
that's ambiguous with any of the other
forms we have so then let's just do it
okay so let's do okay um information on
network packets yeah I think it's better
to say information on network packets
it's more stuff than just the packets
themselves it's a bunch of metadata
right
who do you think that's not correct
really there is meditator right I mean
if you're just talking about the packets
then I mean yeah if you're just showing
other packets themselves I think that
would just imply like you know the byte
payloads okay
captures sets up an interface
you
for capturing information on network
packets
associate
with the specified service with a
specified network service specified
network service yeah that's good okay so
the next thing we want to do is to say
case will be a single port number and we
probably also should support the case of
a list of port numbers
you
so what we decided is that for a it's a
to Muldoon like multiple ones who are
going to support the very basic pattern
of just alternatives I see okay would
you read or do you want that to actually
be a list is it ambiguous to have it be
a list I don't think it is in this form
I don't think so I think that's probably
fine okay so if it's if it's a list of
specifically numbers then that works and
you can also do an interval so if you
want to listen all all ports from 5,000
to 6,000 you just you just do that you
know Wolfram language interval Wow okay
cool well we go to document all of that
um okay set some an interface for
capturing information on network packets
associate with the specified port
um
you
this case is multiple ports
unfortunately as a different pattern
here
you
with any of the ports i buy yes it's or
operation so yeah I mean I guess how
could it be an end
okay okay I know the board supports
abide okay
we're hearing budget I came here so okay
so what is spec here
so spec would be like an association I
guess but well so it made more sense for
a network packet recording so spec would
be if you are specifying the time or the
packet number as well as other things in
an association so I guess it's just the
a SAR case if we don't have time
I'm totally confused here I mean what
you're saying is it's a value case right
which is and then there's an association
if you have multiple key values yes so
you can delete them okay so this one
here is just um it's basically property
error value isn't it yeah but we're not
allowing the possibility of having
network packet capture capture only
certain
you
[Music]
wait a minute I'm sorry I'm I'm very
confused here what what is the OIC
network interface the network interface
specification is another one of those
okay I get it yeah sorry I'm just being
confused here okay record packets ah do
we want to call it I was gonna say we
might want to have a list of specs that
that allow us to get only a subpart of
this giant Association you said I'm
saying like well I'm saying that that
like for example if I want I mean
arguably this is look if I just say
source port destination port
oh I see what you mean you know here you
want to waive it yet by that what on
earth what another yeah oh yeah right
but we might want to just have the the
recording only give these so now for
example I could sales is going to be
kind of cool
let's plot of those and that will show
me rather uninspired Li which the
combinations of source and destination
ports are I think I can conclude nothing
from this okay um okay if you did a sort
around that I bet you'd see like maybe
two or three right because most of the
because there's two points you know the
eight 801 and the fight you know yeah I
bet there's like two actual pairs but
you've seen both sides of the pair yeah
yeah right right
um okay fine so let's sum let's not call
it property then here um what are these
things what what is the generic
description you're calling them keys all
right fine
let's call it key
when and I simplify this captures only
packets
you
um
well so it looks only at packets are so
sable to specified notebook interface
um considers deals would give me a
suggestion I don't want to repeat all
this verbage for every one of these um
you
ah
you
you
let's see now I noticed from the twitch
we have a interesting question here
access to network interface as possible
if the binaries installed a superuser
if I install Mathematica until the
applications typically I'm not sure okay
it's a non super user so so it is
actually possible to capture packets
without being super user there's a
subset of packets that you might not
capture then we should say that we
should say that so this person saying
that you have to set the network
interfaces into promiscuous mode well
promiscuous mode will allow you to
capture packets that aren't necessarily
going to and from your machine oh I see
we gotta talk about that in this
documentation right I mean that's
clearly okay hold on let's just deal
with the wording here
looks only at packets I'm Queen not
I don't know
captures only packets I'll do that
okay so this capturing information on
network packets
this this point about the fact that this
isn't really correct is it because there
are packets that are not going to or
from you
you
sorry I cut off that first thing so
there are by default I don't think most
people have why promiscuous you know
things enabled and so I think by default
all the packets you will see unless
you're you know messing around with
network settings and stuff you will only
see the tune from your machine basically
okay all right fine all right
capture zone
packets
okay
captures packets
for which
how do we want to say that um
you
you
you
you know what I think
you
captures only packets man
captures only packets
matching the specification spec and then
we'll explain that down below
okay um in network packet
worse
okay what is that the service what women
that's the interface right no no that's
the service no no I see and network
packet capture of service um
possible forms
for service
food and then let's make a little table
here so the first thing is a string like
HDPE like a named service
named service eg quotes HTTP is it case
sensitive it shouldn't be I mean yeah I
can make it not okay so let's make it
not case-sensitive just as a courtesy to
the user since I don't think it makes
any difference
um
you
you
okay and the second thing is
you
let's see
a network
an entity of type network service
you
um okay so
okay um
entities can be entered using and we've
got a way caller this is for you we've
got that we got a way to make this
beautiful
well actually we can go look at a
typical page I'm about what's good page
let's try financial data for example
you
oh come on where is it
I don't know we can we find a page us
Brian to find a page where
using freeform linguistics with what
about the walk from alpha page that's an
interesting page to try I no guarantee
that page will work let's see for this
purpose
no it's telling you how to do it
programmatically
um okay you're gonna have to ask Brian
how to do this okay okay um
okay by the way this entity type should
be a link to the entity type page for a
network service another Brian asou okay
okay okay next point
in network packet capture of ports
of Port
ports ports are specified by well what
are these called these are that what is
the name of one of these ports that they
called Unix but what are they called
these ports what is the full name of a
port as in what port on it when network
port ok I mean networks ports are
specified by integers
or the following the spine as follows
can be specified network ports can be
specified um as follows
okay so here we have to say um n and
teacher and from 0 to 6 5 5 3 6 5 rather
that right
you
well actually a single port
you
you
a list of ports
and then we've got the neck
which is a range of ports
you
you
you
you
um single port number numbered n number
n
you
a range of ports from an meant and max
am I correct here no so so a list of
ports means each of the ports you put in
there
so so you should still also have the
list case if I'm gonna do port 80 and
port 443 oh I get it I get it I'm trying
to write it down um okay listen on the
twitch stream seems pleased that we're
putting this feature in which is good
prefer port numbers this person says I
prefer port numbers but some might want
to use I a n/a service names right so
the service name that's the entity case
alright but so we should we should call
them I am a service names yes yeah I
mean yeah we just said a name service
but yeah it's an AI na I heard the I am
a name service
and that's those are registered right
there that there's a definite there's a
single registry for those things yep and
and I don't know that we have all of
them but we have a good chunk of them as
entities
you
okay okay fine
all right so let's go okay so that so
what's an example of where of something
that uses a range of ports some of these
some video for thingies and so on yeah
so Twitter zoom or something that
streaming video might use multiple ports
or you could also be interested in like
if a mural port numbers where you know
for very short is the usual one thing
that okay fair enough
ephemeral ports for like very
short-lived things I wait a minute but I
by the way we should also say all means
all ports right yeah you could do all I
mean all gets ambiguous then as to like
are you doing all services or ports
doesn't make any difference
yeah I guess but muddy why would you put
it under the port's that's not what it
that we not put it but I can put it
there okay right in network packet
capture
spec
spec can
be given
as an association
let's see
um given
and the forum key our eval or as an
association
you
of
or as an association containing multiple
keys and values possible keys
include
you
you
okay what's the ordering here
you know which one should go first yeah
how do we order them in the in the case
of in the actual output yeah so I think
what we talked about is having relative
so packet number then relative time then
the IP address for source IP address
then destination IP address then source
port destination port interface absolute
time and then the beginning right so
let's get the ordering the same here
okay so that source IP address right is
the first thing on the list then yes if
source IP address destination IP address
okay
like hold on this is so grotesque what
we have to do here I am going to do
something horrifying but it'll work
okay source IP address is going in first
right
now is that given as an IP address
object or as bring a string or a knife
okay IP addresses
can be given as strings or as IP address
objects
right an ipv4 ipv6 that's all under
control
yes so so I mean IP address that the the
string when you specified it it can be
either or if you want to say you don't
only use ipv6 packets there's another
design holoholo
there's another issue here so aspect can
be given in this form or as an
association
um spec
okay that's fine okay possible keys
associate
okay sorry go ahead what were you saying
I yeah I should we specify the ipv6
versus IP before is it I mean it's it's
a binary thing it's like either do both
of them he all or do i p p4 or ipv6 I
understand that statement I mean isn't I
P address have a isn't that rapper
doesn't that rapper correctly deal with
this right but there's also another key
where if you only want packets from any
IP address that are ipv4 or I send back
a letter IPC what should we name that
you
by the way we should mention look I
don't know we don't have see also say we
should absolutely mention host lookup as
a seal so here
yeah yeah that's probably the first less
useful one ping time maybe as well as in
see also you know okay but um
do we care about soccer
get a stream from one of the sockets
does that is that relevant
I mean yeah I mean maybe you'd want to
you know start capturing and you know
see your socket messages or something
how would you do that well I mean
eventually what you would do is you'd
use the like the asynchronous task
version of this but that won't be ready
for 11.3 so okay okay that's so what you
want to do is this would say so possible
keys include so we could say something
like IP address type
you could say v4 o v6 so it would be the
possible values would be all v6 v4
method or should we also do ipv4 ipv6 I
don't know but let's is is that when you
give this here you can see plainly from
the sorcerer test which by the way is
this an IP address wrapper thing or is
that just a Nokia grid if you copy the
data it'll paste as an IP address around
the thing but you asked us to have it
format and more nicely inside a data set
so great tastic so if this is an ipv6
address it'll show up here in a
reasonably civilized way yes yeah I mean
it'll show up with the Cohens yeah right
okay so I think we should say source IP
destination IP address IP address type
you
well is that for destination or for
source or for both it has to be source
IP address type well so so for each each
of these like the IP address the port
and I guess also the IP address type
there's three versions there source
destination or just for generic which
means either or
you
which is I see I see I see I see I see
well so should that be first in our list
here IP address aye sir
I have a bad feeling that the AdRoll
mechanism doesn't work properly at the
first element there but that's okay
all right so then then what you're
saying is that we we listing here
you
um
packets going to
or from
well I peered at the source or
destination IP address
yeah which which means that for a packet
to match it has to either be the source
or the destination right
okay so
now in principle we could say you know
it could say IP address ROV 4 it would
not be ambiguous if you just used a
string for IP address here and you just
said IP address ROV 4
so I'm saying because that isn't a valid
IP address
you
it's clearer if we say IP address type G
agree
that's fine with me
you
you
you
eg v4 should the V be capitalized I
don't know appropriate if it's supposed
to be capitalist or not capital well I
mean it normally is lowercase but but
for our typical conventions I think it's
probably should be uppercase like that
okay so you'll be you'll be able to get
this implemented this this type thing
yes yeah yeah that's right yeah muted
yeah that should be fine okay and and
just just to be clear so we'll document
it as capital P but we should also
presume x lowercase yeah except ipv4 and
so on
sure do you think you're trading
everything can fit right but do you
think it should be ipv4 as the as the
name I mean if you really encode IP
address type herro oh it's probably okay
the Wikipedia uses capital IP and then
lowercase V I know that already I know
and that's the usual thing that's what
that looks better actually let's do that
as the canonical okay okay
you
okay next we have
port source or destination port right
yes
yes
you
you
okay so now we would have source port
and then destination port
you
hi
and the final thing is interface yep
which is network interface device yep
and for that network interface network
interface eg en0 right yeah that's this
example of one and then maybe there
should be another note just a minute I
know that that dollar network interface
is gives all of them right that's the
note below yeah anybody know how to do
what I'm trying to do right now
help special in the world literal a
minute
Oh doesn't seem to work maybe that
worked again that's something for Brian
Carla for these these things here okay
can be given as strings or IP address
objects
all values for
key
um
you
let's see
let's see all okay we can
when at the pcap filter okay so this
needs to be a separate thing right that
needs to be another thing down here
you
yeah I mean it really can be used in
place of any of the above ones and it
doesn't really you know combine its
either/or thing right what do you mean I
mean instead of this the whole spec
could be a pcap string yes but it can
you combine something in this unknown it
would be very hard to do that why well
because then we have to take the string
specification and it could be you know a
fairly complicated thing and parse that
into the symbolic Association and then
merge the two being yeah could be in
conflict with each other right by
clicking right - okay no that's okay we
can just say the P cap fills a role pcap
filter specification
yeah and if that exists if you're using
if you use piec a filter at the
education that is you know all the unit
yeah that overall okay IP addresses okay
see
and to face it the values for the
interface key
um
you said this possible values for the
inter case key hum
you
you
can be any
of the
things
you
oh gosh any element
in
or values for the interface commitment
an or list or list of these or
you
what is dull and I look interfaces like
for my machine is it like a list of
thousands of creatures when we've looked
at it before it's like 14 or 15 random
things so if I said for example here
like en 6 or something here if I say
interface arrow the individual rule I
don't think is ok ok so it has to be an
association arrow en6 let's find out
where the en 6 is very active here well
that's kind of weird is that is that
what you're going to capture from the n6
or is it going to capture for me in zero
I think sex even though it said it
captured from me and zero yeah maybe in
success we did yeah the GUI that was
presented I think kind of breaks that's
my vacation but but that's just because
it's outdated and I haven't fine okay
okay
you
um string
see the key can be used um
oh gosh as a string
um and is setting
given 4p
filter overrides all other settings that
right okay now we got to make these
comments about promiscuous mode and so
on right yes so I think this has to list
one of the things it needs to list early
on is Dola network interfaces so the
first thing it lists is network packet
recording darling network interfaces
and the
up in these other things right so
another thing it needs to say is on
Windows computers system install of what
pcap now I have it as windy cap but when
P cap
see lowercase
it's not what it is here I mean it's a
Wimpy kept is like a fork of pcap that's
maintained and that's what they call it
on the windy cap with a website like
this yes ok systematical may be required
before network packet capture
is used
[Music]
that worked
capture captures
what should I say about this promiscuous
mode thing I think that because I mean
that's it's subject to external
configuration right like user has to go
and manually do stuff kind of time
[Music]
captures only packets accessible it's
kind of obvious yeah accessible to the
crazies
yeah to the current to the user running
to the current user you could run it as
pseudo and you know then you could see
everything but
you
and does what and may not include
typically does not include promiscuous
mode packets or something yeah I guess
so
I mean yeah we should have the word
promiscuous in there so because that's
the technical term for it if I could
spell it promiscuous mode packets okay
okay is it always if you are superuser
do you always get those packets if you
have to switch it on in the OS well you
have to you have to switch it on super
user can switch it on but I understand
there's a certain lack of examples here
okay I am supposed to do another meeting
for a while um and then we are back to
this
um
okay and what we've got to do then in
fact you could try and move over some of
this material to network packet
recording we've also got to do Network
dollar network interfaces as well yep
and then there's also a dollar sign
default network interface Oh
element to this no because because by
default we captured all of them right is
the default so what why do we care about
the foot what is dollar default network
interface so the operating system is
this concept of like a default one that
it uses like you know if you open up
Chrome what network interfaces chrome
use if you don't tell what can I say is
it obvious that that um so I would put
it last I mean I don't think or because
I think it's something you might very
well care about only asking about what
happens on the default network interface
but to get it you're gonna have to say
network packet capture of quotes
I mean is it obvious that the right
default is all network interfaces rather
than just your default network interface
I think the most useful thing is default
there is to do all by default right
because I mean you know if you're just
you know you start up the graphical
interface and you're like I want to
capture packets you might not always
know what interface the packets you're
interested on are traveling on so okay
capturing one all would help you find
them okay great shall I I'll push this
back and then maybe you can try and
click great and I should be back with
you guys in about 45 minutes and for
those on this live stream I will be back
we will be back in about 45 minutes so
see you then